The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Ready for
the least squares lecture,
lecture 11?
Homework is just being
posted on the web.
It'll be due, it's really
to help you practice, get
some experience on these
sections for the first exam.
That's Tuesday evening.
So eight days away.
So the homework will
be due the day after.
And actually, we'll try to move
the review session to Monday
next week so you can ask me any
questions about the homework
or any review material.
So that's all a week
away and this week we
get two great examples.
Least squares is one
that comes today.
But could I first, because
I keep learning more--
And I've got your MATLAB
homeworks to return.
I keep sort of learning a little
more from your MATLAB results
and I think because
we spoke about it,
it would be worth speaking
just a little more.
So I'm going to take ten minutes
about this convection-diffusion
equation in which I put in a
coefficient d, a diffusivity,
just to help get
the units right.
So this is your example.
And it had d=1 of course.
Well first I realized
that later in the book
I completely forgot that
I discussed this problem.
About page 509, I think.
I discussed it a little bit.
And just because
it's worth, since we
invested a little time, the
little bit more will pay off.
So first of all,
the point is here
we have convection
competing with diffusion.
And always there's some
non-dimensional number.
Here it's called
the Peclet number.
Actually, there's an accent
on one of those e's, Péclet
number.
Which measures the ratio,
the importance of convection
relative to diffusion.
So it's V times a length scale
in the problem, divided by d.
So then that has the
same units as that,
if the result is dimensionless.
Maybe you know the
Reynolds number.
This is very like the Reynolds
number, which also measures,
in Navier-Stokes equation,
the importance of convection,
advection, and diffusion.
There, in that equation,
the velocity V,
that's a non-linear
equation, Navier-Stokes,
it's tremendously important
and many codes to solve it,
lots of discussion,
theory still not complete.
In that problem, the V is u.
It's non-linear
and the term there
that we took as a
constant, as a given
constant V, it's the same as u.
So in the Reynolds number, this
would be u, a typical velocity
u, times a typical
length scale, which
would be like one in our zero to
one problem, divided by d or mu
or nu, whatever number we use.
So it's like the
Reynolds number.
And then it's turned
out for this problem
that people also use
a number that gets
called the cell
Peclet number where
the length is taken
to be half the cell
size, delta x over two.
Let me call that number P. So
that's P. And what's my point?
This equation's important enough
to sort of see a little more
about it than just the
numbers that come out.
So the MATLAB homework,
which you did really well,
set up finite
differences for this.
Right?
And found the eigenvalues
and solutions.
It's the eigenvalues I want
to say a little more about.
Because you set up a matrix
K over delta x squared and V
times the centered
difference over delta x.
And I guess I call that whole
combination L, and asked you
about the eigenvalues of L. And
you printed them out correctly.
But there's more there than
I think we have understood.
And I want to make some
more comments about that.
Because it's quite important.
And the comments are clearest if
I just reduce to a n equal two.
So that matrix, well
the off-diagonal part
of that matrix had some
number b and some number c.
Actually we could figure
out what was the b in this.
This produced a minus one,
two, minus one, right?
So part of the b was the minus
one over delta x squared.
And then from this was
a plus V and a one over,
well it's a centered
difference so I
should divide by 2 delta x.
Is that right?
Is that what a typical
off-diagonal thing
in the matrix that
you displayed?
That's what's coming from
the off-diagonal of K.
And this is what's coming
from the centered difference
C. And then what
would this c thing be?
Well the c is below the diagonal
so it's also that minus one
over delta x squared.
But now this is a difference,
so it's going to be a minus,
right?
I think those would have been
your entries for b and c.
So can we just think first,
what are the eigenvalues
of that matrix?
It's a two by two,
simple problem.
The trace is zero plus zero.
So that the eigenvalues
will be a plus minus pair
because they have
to add to zero.
And I think that's the
plus minus pair you get.
Let's just check.
What's our other check?
They will add to zero, the
plus the square root and minus
the square root.
And the product of
the two eigenvalues,
lambda_1 times
lambda_2, will be,
we have one of them is
plus, one with a minus,
so it'd be minus bc.
And that's correctly
the determinant.
So it's good.
These are the
correct eigenvalues.
Now let me ask you about
the signs of b and c.
If b and c have the same signs,
like maybe even equal, one,
one, what are the eigenvalues?
So in that symmetric
case if b and c
are equal the eigenvalues are?
Right here.
If b and c are equal,
say equal to one,
the eigenvalues are
plus and minus one.
But what if the
signs are opposite?
Everything changes.
What if b is one
and c is minus one?
That matrix would then
be a 90 degree rotation.
It would be anti-symmetric if
b was one and c was minus one.
Our formula is still correct,
but what does it give us?
If b is one and c is minus
one what have I got here?
I've got i.
So the eigenvalues change
from plus and minus one
in the symmetric case
to plus and minus i
in the anti-symmetric case.
And I think that's what you guys
saw at a certain level of V.
I hope you did because that was
the point about eigenvalues.
Now you may say, what
about the diagonal?
Well I claim diagonal
is very simple.
What's the diagonal?
Now I'm going to allow
myself a diagonal
and I'm just going to change--
What happens if I have a and a?
Same entry on the diagonal.
What are the eigenvalues now?
This is just like,
a great chance
to do some basic
eigenvalue stuff.
What are the eigenvalues
of that matrix?
Well I've added a
times the identity.
I've just shifted
that matrix by a.
So the eigenvalues
all shift by a.
So the eigenvalues are
now a plus and minus.
So no big deal.
So you say that the a is
actually not important,
not the key to this
question of are they real
or do they go complex.
So the eigenvalues
of this are real when
b and c have the same sign.
If b and c have the same sign, I
have a square root, no problem.
When b and c have opposite
sign, what do I get?
When b and c have
opposite sign, I'm
taking the square root
of a negative number
and I've gone complex.
Do you see that the change
from real eigenvalues, which
gives a nice curve, to
complex eigenvalues,
which gives a very bumpy
curve for the solution,
just happens when
like, for example,
b-- Is it b that's going
to go to zero maybe?
And then beyond that?
Well this sign is for
sure negative, right?
So c is staying negative.
And originally for a little
delta x, b is also negative.
What's happening here?
I think that the transition
that you I hope observed
comes when b hits zero.
When the combination of V and
delta x is such that at b=0 we
switch from real eigenvalues
to complex eigenvalues.
And when is b=0?
That's when this negative
guy off the diagonal
just exactly cancels this one.
So b is zero when what?
So if this equals this,
one over delta x squared
is equal to V over two delta x.
Let me multiply
both sides by delta
x squared so that I
have a nice one there,
multiplying by delta x squared
will put a delta x up here.
And what have we discovered?
This is why I wanted
you to see it.
That the transition comes
when the Peclet number is one.
So that Peclet number,
that cell Peclet number
is exactly the point that
we observed of transition
from real eigenvalues
to complex eigenvalues.
And that's the transition.
So it's that combination,
this is the Peclet number,
cell Peclet number, it's that
combination, P_cell maybe.
We've done the
computations and now
we gradually get
back to the meaning.
And I just wanted
to take this step
back to the meaning to see
when do those numbers start
going complex.
You may have noticed
or you may not
have noticed that
it'll happen when
one of those, when that
upper diagonal changes sign.
Now you could say, okay
that's the eigenvalues.
What's the consequences for
the shape of the solution?
Well, I haven't
figured all that out.
I'd be happy to have some
more thoughts about that.
But what you noticed, I
think, in the computations is
if V got too big so that
that P was bigger than one,
if V got too big, so
convection was dominating
and our delta x was not
small enough to deal with it,
you should have seen the
points on the discrete values
were oscillating instead
of a proper smooth-- I
mean, the proper,
with a large V,
the correct solution, I think,
is practically nothing for here
and then it goes, this
is a really large V,
take V to a thousand
or something.
It climbs up like mad.
Here's the halfway
point where the load is.
And then it goes along here and
then it climbs down like mad
to satisfy the
boundary condition.
I didn't know that that's
what would happen for large V.
What I'm saying is,
and undoubtedly it
could be understood
physically, so I
guess what I'm saying
is there's just
more good stuff in any
computation than purely
the numbers.
And this is part of the
good stuff in that example.
I hope you liked that.
Because I mean, here you
did the work but then,
to understand it is
frankly still under way.
More thinking to do.
That's back to least squares.
Here's today's lecture.
So remember where we
started last time.
Au=b.
Last time I wrote f.
I regret it terribly.
I can't fix it.
But it's b.
I want b there to be
the right-hand side.
And I jumped to the equation
that determines the best u.
There's no exact u because
we've got too many equations.
You remember the set-up,
we have too many equations.
There's noise in
the measurements
and we can't get the
error down to zero.
There's some error.
And the best u was
given by that equation
and we want to say why.
And understand it from
two or three ways.
Calculus, geometry, everything.
Can I first, because I love
my little framework here,
fit it in because it's quite
important, this example
and then others fit in.
So u is our unknown as always.
Then the matrix A in the
problem produces an Au.
Now two things to
notice about e,
which, that's the same letter
I used for elongation, here
it's standing for error.
Two things to notice.
One is that the source
term, which is b,
comes in at this point
of the framework.
When we had external forces
on springs and on masses
it came in at this point.
We had an f there.
So that's why I'd like to
keep those two separate.
The b's are like voltage
sources, they come in here.
The f's are will be like current
sources, they'll come in there.
Actually it's beautiful.
One more thing to notice.
A is coming with a minus sign.
In mechanics, in masses
and springs, we had e=Au.
Here it's natural
to work with this,
the error or the residual b-Au.
And that minus sign
is natural in physics
and in electrical
engineering and hydraulics,
you know, flow-- Where's that
minus sign coming from in flow?
Well, flow goes from the
higher point to the lower.
Higher voltage to
the lower voltage.
And that usually
produces that minus sign.
No big deal, of course.
So that step is fine
with the framework.
What do we expect
in that middle step?
So what's our name for the
matrix that goes there?
Everybody's gotta
know this framework.
C, right?
Only I've been taking
unweighted least squares.
So for unweighted least
squares, C will be the identity.
And C doesn't show
in our equations.
So C is the identity
when there are
no weights, when all the
equations are equally reliable.
And that's pretty
common, of course.
But not always.
And we'll think, okay,
there is a weight e.
So w, which is Ce, is weighted
errors, you could say.
So the letter w comes
up appropriately again.
Weighted errors.
And then what's
the good weighting?
May I stay with C equal the
identity for the moment?
Unweighted least squares,
because that's by far the most
common.
And then w and e are the same.
C is the identity.
And finally, there's the
last step in our framework
where we always expect
to see A transpose.
And we do.
And we have to say why.
So that's where I
left it last time.
That this was the picture.
This is the equation.
If I had a matrix C, it
would go there and there.
Right?
Because I'd have b-Au and then
I'd apply C before A transpose.
So C would slip in there before
A transpose on both sides.
So that would,
with the C's there,
that would be the weighted
least squares equation.
You see that it would
be A transpose C
A instead of A transpose A, but
still the main facts are there.
So where does the
equation come from?
So one source, one way to get
the equation is from calculus.
From minimizing,
from minimizing.
Set a derivative
to zero, calculus.
And what's the quantity
we're minimizing?
We're minimizing
that squared error
because this is least squares.
We're minimizing this e
transpose e, the length of e
squared.
The sum of the
squares of the errors.
Which is (b-Au)
transpose (b-Au).
Again I could say where
to slip in the C matrix.
If there was one, it
would go in there.
C would go in there,
C would go in there.
There'd be a C in the equation.
But let's keep C
to be the identity.
So I minimized.
It's a quadratic.
It's got u's times
u's, so second degree.
And what's the coefficient
in that second degree part?
Well, the second degree part is
coming from (Au)^ transpose Au.
Right?
This times this is
going to be linear.
That times that is just
going to be a constant,
its derivative is zero.
But this times
this is altogether,
that times that is the u
transpose A transpose Au.
Right?
So that's the quadratic part.
And my only point is it's
like our old stiffness matrix.
We're seeing the matrix
in here is A transpose A.
In other words,
when I do calculus
and maybe I'd prefer to see
something than just compute
away, take derivatives
mechanically.
So I'm going to leave that
which is done in the text,
finding the derivative,
setting to zero.
And what does it give?
It gives us our equation.
So that equation will come
when I set the derivatives
of this thing to zero.
So that's one totally
okay approach.
But I like to see
a picture with it.
I hope that's alright.
To take the second
approach is to see
why A transpose w equal zero.
Why is that?
What's going on
in that key step?
This is always the key step.
This is like the set-up step.
This is the weighting step
with constants coming in.
And here's the key step.
Let's see that.
So my picture.
Let me draw that picture again.
And my example was in
three dimensions, so m=3.
I've got three equations.
The matrix A, oh I'm afraid
I don't remember what it was,
but I think it was
something like 1,
1, 1; 0, 1, 3,
was that maybe it?
Just to connect to last time.
And what I'm now calling b was
the vector [1, 2, 3] was it?
Or was it not?
It was [0, 1, 2] maybe?
That's right?
And what was the point?
If I draw the vector b
it goes there somewhere.
If I draw the first column
of A, it goes here somewhere.
If I draw the second column
of A, it goes there somewhere.
And if I draw all
combinations of these columns,
all combinations of that vector
and that vector, what do I get?
I get a plane.
There it is.
That's the plane.
This is from column one.
Here's column two.
This plane is the column
plane or column space.
It's the column
space of A because it
comes from the columns of A.
Now what's the point
about this plane?
The point is that if b is on
the plane then I'm golden.
If b is on the plane then b is
a combination of the columns,
that's what the plane is, and
I have a solution to Au=b.
So b on a plane, b on the
plane means Au=b is solvable.
And it could happen, of course.
Like perfect measurements.
But we can't expect it.
When we have three measurements
or 100 measurements or 10,000
measurements we can't
expect perfection.
So usually b will
be off the plane.
Now what?
What happens when
b is off the plane?
Let me just complete
that picture.
And you know what's coming.
If we're going to get-- Au or Au
hat is going to be on the plane
so I'm looking for
the best u hat.
Can I just erase
this to make space
for what you know
I'm going to draw?
Here are these little columns,
let me put them there.
What am I going to draw?
The projection.
I'm going to draw,
what's the projection?
The projection is
the nearest point
that is in the plane to the
b that's not in the plane.
So here's the projection p.
I drop down this thing.
There's the projection
p, little p.
That's the projection
of b onto the plane.
I think your mind says yeah,
that's the right choice.
And do you want to
tell me what this?
That is the part that
we can't deal with.
The part we can't improve.
We've made it as small
as we could and it's e.
That's the error e and
this p is the best guy
that is in the plane.
Do you see that
this is the picture.
You get an actual picture
of what's going on.
You're splitting b,
the measurements,
into the part you can deal with,
the projection, the Au hat that
is in the column space.
It is a combination
of the columns.
Those points do lie
on a line if I'm
doing straight line fitting.
And the part that you can't deal
with, the e, the difference,
b-Au, which is not in the plane.
And now I'm still looking
for the equations.
Right?
I've just named some stuff.
But I haven't got an
equation for that projection.
So what's the key fact?
What's the key fact
in this picture that's
going to lead me to an
equation for p and e
and u hat and everything?
The key fact is that that
dotted line is perpendicular,
perpendicular to the plane.
If I'm looking for
the closest point,
everybody knows project, that's
what projection involves.
Go perpendicular.
This is a right angle.
That e is perpendicular
to the whole plane.
Not only perpendicular
to p, it's
perpendicular to
everybody in that plane.
Right?
I'm dropping the
perpendicular to the plane.
Do you accept that?
Because if you
do, we're through.
We just write down the
equations for perpendicular
and we've got what we
want from the picture
instead of from a calculation.
So what's the idea?
So e is perpendicular
to the first column.
So b in the plane,
we would be golden.
Let's suppose we're
not in the plane.
So now we have this 90 degree
angle, this perpendicular
projection.
And it tells me that
the first column--
oh I better name the columns.
Can I just call this column a_1?
That first column is a_1 and
the second column is a_2.
So those two columns,
whatever they are,
are the guys whose
combinations give us the plane.
And it's the plane that
we're projecting onto.
It's the plane of
all combinations
that comes up here.
So what's this 90 degree angle?
It says that a_1 is
perpendicular to p, right?
Sorry!
Say that right for me.
The first equation says that
a_1 and what are perpendicular?
e, thank you, e.
So the first equation says
that a_1 transpose e is zero.
And the second equation says
that a_2 transpose e is zero.
Those are my two equations.
I have to convert those
now into matrix language
because I've done them
two separate-- vector,
I mean vector
language, and I want
to get into matrix language.
But it's easy to do.
Here I have, look, if
I have two equations,
let's get a matrix here.
What's it saying? a_1
transpose and a_2 transpose,
what are those?
They're the rows of A transpose.
So the matrix way to say that
is A transpose e equal zero.
In other words, this is
saying both at once, right?
The first row of A
transpose times e
gives zero, the second row of
A transpose times e is zero.
So it's A transpose
e equal zero which
is what we wanted in this case
where w and e are the same.
Because C is the identity.
And let's just go one
step further and see.
That's A transpose
(b-Au hat) is zero.
Remember this zero
stands for [0, 0], right?
I wanted to put the
two equations together.
So I've got two components
on the right-hand side.
And then I just
plugged in what b is.
And now everybody
sees it, right?
Everybody sees that
we've got the picture,
this 90 degree angle was
the key to these equations.
Because if I put A transpose
A u hat onto the other side,
I've got exactly the normal
equations that I wanted.
We're taking the time
to see the picture
and the form of the equations.
Then I can plug in the
numbers, but the thinking
is where the
equations come from.
We're there.
Now what to do next?
Now we've understood where
the equations come from.
I didn't go through the steps
of taking the derivatives,
but that would work.
Or this picture.
I love this picture.
Let me stay with that
a little bit longer.
What is u hat?
Can I just go over here to say,
okay what have we got here?
We started with Au=b and then we
got the projection was A u hat.
But now what is u hat?
I'm just going to assemble
things here. u hat,
we figured out by
the 90 degree angle,
comes from this equation,
which is that equation, which
is A transpose A u
hat equal A transpose
b, the central equation.
That's the central equation.
Now plug in u hat here so I get
a formula for the projection.
While we're doing all this
stuff we might just as well
put those two pieces
together and have
a formula for the projection.
So it's A times u hat-- I
hope you like this formula.
It's kind of goofy-looking
but you'll remember it.
What is u hat?
The whole point is that
this matrix is good.
It's square, it's
symmetric, it's invertible,
we'll have another
word about that.
And now I'll invert it.
Times A transpose b.
That's the goofy formula
that I wanted you to see.
The projection of vector b onto
these columns of A comes from
applying this matrix, sometimes
I call it the matrix of four
A's.
Now it's worth looking
at that matrix.
Often I'll call
that matrix capital
P. It's the projection matrix.
You give me any vector b, I
multiply it by this matrix
and I get the projection.
It's just worth seeing
what this matrix P,
these four A's, what are
projection matrices like.
Now first of all,
when I have an inverse
of a product, any
reasonable person
would say okay, split
that into A inverse
times A transpose inverse
and simplify the whole thing.
And what will happen?
It's not going to be legal,
but let's just pretend.
If I split this into A inverse
times A transpose inverse
and simplify, what
do I get for P?
Do you see it?
I'll get A and if
I try to split this
into that, what do I have here?
I've got the identity.
That's the identity.
The result is the identity.
That doesn't look good,
right? p is not the same as b.
This matrix cannot be split
into these two pieces.
A is rectangular,
that's its problem.
If A was square, oh yeah,
think about the case
when A is square.
Suppose m equals n.
That case'll be included here.
If m equals n and my matrix
is square and invertible and
golden then all this works.
The projection is
the identity matrix.
And what's with my picture?
What's my picture
look like in the case
where A is a square matrix?
Give it another column.
Fit this thing by a quadratic.
So if I was fitting instead
of by a straight line,
by a quadratic, it
turns out I'd have
zero squared, one squared and
three squared in that column.
I'd have a three
by three matrix.
It comes out to be invertible.
Now what's going on?
Now what's my problem Au=b?
Now suddenly m is still three,
but now n is three. b is?
And what happened to the
plane? b is in there.
And now what's there?
It's now the
combinations of what?
Why did that plane come in?
That was the combinations
of two columns.
But now I've got three.
The combinations
of three columns,
those three columns of an
invertible matrix is what?
Are you with me?
If I have a three by three
invertible matrix, these three
columns independent, pointing
off different directions,
not in a plane, then when I
take the combinations I get?
I get R^3.
I get the whole space.
I get everybody.
Every vector including
this b and any other b
you want to suggest
will be a combination
of these three guys.
So what's my picture here?
My picture is that plane
grew to be the whole space.
So what's the projection of b
onto the whole space? b itself.
And what's the error?
Zero.
Good.
So that's the nice case.
That's the standard
case that we've
thought about in the
past when m equalled n.
In that case P is the identity
and that'd be all true.
But normally it's not.
So I want to come
back to this P just
to mention an
important fact about P.
And it comes again
from the picture.
So this is a projection.
This is what I'm calling
the projection matrix.
It's the matrix that
does the projection.
And there it is.
Four A's in a row
that multiplies b.
Now here's my little question.
So linear algebra's full
of these different kinds
of matrices.
Rotations, reflections,
symmetric matrices,
Markov matrices, so it's just
every problem has matrices.
Now here we have a
projection matrix.
Now what I want to know is what
happens if I project again?
If I take the vector b,
any vector b, I project it
and then I project again.
So project twice and just tell
me, you know what will happen.
I'm back to this picture.
I project b to P and
now I project again.
Where do I go?
Same place, right?
Once I'm in the
plane the projection
stays right where it is.
So what does that tell me?
That tells me that P squared
on b is the same as P on b.
If I project twice, no change.
It's the same as
projecting once.
So the projection matrix has the
property that P squared is P.
And actually, we should
be able to see it
if I write out this whole
miserable thing twice.
So now I'm going to
be up to eight A's.
Sorry about this, but I
promise not to do P cubed.
A times (A transpose A) inverse
times A transpose, that's
one P. I'll write it again.
There's the second P.
So that's P squared.
Do you see anything good there?
Do you see in here A
transpose A, that combination
and that combination there.
This cancels that to
give the identity.
And what am I left with?
I'm left with A, the inverse
times A transpose, which
was exactly P. The algebra
is just coming along
with the understanding
that we know.
So that's the projection matrix.
So this is the theory of
projections in a nutshell,
in a nutshell.
This is projections onto
the column space of A.
Now I have to remind you
about one little math point.
Not so little, I guess.
How could I say little for math?
Is A transpose A invertible?
We're plowing along
as if it is, that's
going to be our assumption.
But what's the condition
for A transpose A
to be invertible, which
allows all this to work?
When is A transpose
A invertible?
What I'm doing here
now is I'm separating
the positive definite one,
when A transpose A is positive
definite, the good normal case
when all our equations work,
from the semi-definite
one where we overlooked
the fact that A transpose
A-- where somehow
the experiment
wasn't well set up,
we got an A transpose
A that is singular.
And just to see, when
could that happen?
Let me just remind you.
This is important.
Why don't I give it some space.
It's really straightforward.
Let me just go through
those steps again.
If it's not invertible, if
some A transpose A u is zero.
This is always the
risk that we have
to check out and be sure we
don't have and understand.
So if A transpose Au is zero,
then that would lead us,
I could multiply both
sides by u transpose.
u transpose zero, right?
Safe.
Multiply whatever
that u might be,
multiply both sides
by u transpose.
But what is u transpose zero?
Zero, nothing there.
Now how do I
understand this guy?
Well you remember the key.
Everybody remembers the key?
You look at that
thing and you say hey,
if I put in parentheses
in the right place that's
the length of Au squared.
So that's the small trick that
this multiplying by u transpose
and then seeing what
you've got that we've done
and you should know it.
And now if the length squared
is zero, what does that
tell me about Au?
If I have a vector here
whose length is zero,
that vector must be?
Zero.
Zero vector's the only one for
which the sum of the squares
will give zero.
And if Au is zero I
could multiply both sides
by A transpose and
complete the loop.
Actually I thought of that when
I was swimming this morning,
that line.
Just to see once again when,
it's sort of interesting then.
A transpose Au equal zero
which is the bad thing
we hope we don't deal with.
And when does it happen?
It happens when Au is zero.
So our assumption
always has to be this,
that there aren't any
u's, except the zero
vector of course, that's
always going to happen,
but we always have to assume
that Au is never zero.
So we have to avoid this.
So to avoid that assume A has
-- this is the key word --
independent columns.
Since this is a
combination of the columns,
independent columns means what?
It means that the only
combination of the columns
to give zero is the
zero combination.
So did I have independent
columns over here?
I sure did.
That column and that column were
off in different directions,
they were independent.
And that's why I
knew we were fine.
A transpose A was zero.
I would have to really
struggle to find a,
well I'd have to think a
bit to find an example where
we run into trouble.
These squares, well I certainly
could in many applications,
but the straightforward
applications
of fitting a straight
line, A is going
to be a column vector of ones
and a column vector of times
and those are different
directions and no problem.
So that's A transpose A.
What else to do with this topic?
Because there's a whole
world of estimation.
I mean, statistics is looking
over our shoulder I guess.
Really, we should realize
that a statistician
is, say, yeah, I know that
but, and then going on.
And what is that guy, what
more does he have to say?
So you've got the central ideas.
I guess the statistician
comes in in this, that's
the statistical constant now.
And what do
statisticians compute?
They say you've
got errors, right?
And of course, in
any particular case
we don't know what that
error is, otherwise
we could take it out and
we'd get exact solutions.
We don't know what the error is.
What is reasonable
to know about errors?
We're doing a little
statistics here.
Somehow that error,
that particular error
of the experiment that we
happen to run, and if we ran it
again we'd get a
different error,
those errors come out of some
sort of error population.
Like dark matter or something.
Just like, a bunch of
errors are out there, noise.
And what could we
reasonably assume
that we know about the noise?
We could assume that its
average is zero, mean zero.
So statisticians always,
that just resets the meter.
Right?
If you had a meter or a clock
that was always three minutes
ahead (like this one)
you would reset it.
And we'll do that one day.
So you'd reset to
get the average zero.
But that doesn't mean
every error is zero, right?
That just means the
average error is zero.
So what's the other number?
What's the other number
that statisticians live on?
It's the deviation
or its square,
which is called the variance.
Right.
Variance.
So that's the thing
that you could
assume that the errors have mean
zero and have some variance.
You could suppose that you knew
something about the variance.
You don't know the
individual errors,
but you know whether the
errors are like, are very small
or close to zero or large.
So this is a small variance.
So one over sigma is
sort of that distance.
One over sigma.
Here, this is a
large variance where
the magnitude of the error
could be much larger from this.
So those are the two
numbers, mean zero,
that leaves us just one
number, and the variance,
the standard deviation sigma
or the variance sigma squared.
One moment on these squares.
Let me just say what the
weighting matrix would be.
And then I can tell
you in a moment why.
What would the
weighting matrix be
if our three
equations, you know,
that came from one
measurement and this
came from a second
came from a third measurement.
If they came from
different meter readers
with different
variances, suppose,
then the right C matrix will be
a diagonal matrix, beautiful.
And what sits up there, what
sits there, what sits there?
We don't have spring
constants anymore.
We have statistics constants.
And what's the number
that goes there?
That one is the third guy.
So it's associated with
the third measurement.
It's one over sigma_3 squared.
Those are the numbers
that go on the diagonal,
the inverses of the variances.
And just to see that
that makes sense.
If that number is unreliable,
if it has a large variance
then I want to give it
little weight, right?
If this third meter
is very unreliable
I'm not going to
throw it out entirely,
but I know that it's
variance is large
and therefore I'll weight
that equation only a little,
with a small weight.
Suppose sigma_2, so this guy
is one over sigma_2 squared,
suppose this is an
extremely reliable meter.
That measurement has
little expected error.
Then I want to
weight it heavily.
So it has a small sigma_2 and
that gives it a large weight.
And sigma_1 similarly.
So that's the
weighting for the case
that you can actually
hope to use in practice.
I'll just mention that
statisticians would also
say, wait a minute.
Measurement two and measurement
three might be interconnected.
They might not be independent.
There might be a covariance.
And then that gets them into
more great linear algebra
actually.
But if I want a
diagonal matrix C
that's the case when my
measurements are independent.
And basically, I'm
whitening the system.
I'm making the system white,
making it all equal variances
by rescaling.
By weighting the equations.
Okay, thanks.
Wednesday is the
next big example
of the framework with b and f.
See you then.